look let's be honest I said I was going
to release a document and um
clearly we haven't
okay April fools April Fools
we're talking about uh Universal
theories of everything perhaps a new one
created by today's guest Eric Weinstein
uh and that goes by the moniker
geometric Unity
what we're talking about is crazy
I think it's really important to just
own up to the fact that for people who
want sober physics
this is probably not the channel for you
today
um
we look at our history everybody who's
proposed new physical law
uh and gotten it right it had errors the
the problem is is that we're not in an
adult phase where we faced up to the
fact that we have almost 50 years of
stagnation
and what you're seeing with this
proliferation of new claimants to have
fundamental theories is in part
that string theory has finally weakened
itself and the Aging of the particular
cohort which is Baby Boomers who are the
string theory proponents they've gotten
weak enough that effectively other
people feel emboldened and I think you
know Stephen Wolfram said this recently
that in a previous era he would have
expected to have been attacked
but we've been waiting around for so
long that perhaps that
the political economy of unification and
wild ideas has changed someone what are
the inputs there are the players the
matter players there are the the Gage
bosons there are new predictions there
are new uh New Concepts but there's a
lot of weirdness why why the Lorenz
group why su-3 cross su2 cross U1 for
the internal symmetries generating the
forces why three families
and
I I thought that something that many
younger viewers uh may not be aware of
is that things really changed
around 19
83-84 and if you think about the
original anomaly uh cancellation of
green and Schwartz in 1984 I believe
um you could ask what was physics like
right before that moment and I think
it's absolutely shocking because we
don't realize the extent to which the
string theorists really redefined what
the major problems in physics were I
think most people in the post-string era
somehow believe that the major issue is
quantum gravity and
I don't really I I just find it
astounding because that's really what
the string theorists were selling so I I
think that a lot of things got done to
shore up what we do to mature input into
a quantum theory
it just it wasn't physics per se it was
sort of the mathematics of physics and I
think that that was very frustrating
which is you know it sort of to
physicists it's yeoman's work they
wanted to go to Stockholm
uh and they ended up you know winning
the first Fields medal won by a
physicist and I think
it's weird it's like what is your time
your time is whatever it is that can be
done and they thought their time was to
quantize gravity well guess again nature
said we have something incredibly
important so I feel like I'm trying to
rescue their legacy they want to go down
as string theorists for the most part
and they want to say that string theory
was the more successful most successful
of any claimant maybe that structure
ultimately carries the day
but I do think that the idea that
they're entitled to this many pivots
uh without
having to become self-reflective is
preposterous what do you say to the
younger people who say they they can't
understand it they can't comprehend
geometric Unity we can say what
geometric Unity actually is we can draw
pictures people can get it and in fact
um I was talking to my good buddy Joe
Rogan earlier today and a particular
group of people who listen to my podcast
put up a site for Joe called pull that
up Jamie
uh.com Jamie could you bring up
something called boskin Wild versus mild
I know what you're saying
because I want to be joyous I want to
produce positive things that uplift us
that give us a hope of breaking like the
einsteinian speed limit you know if this
is wrong I want to know we've had
insufferable members of our community
for a very long time and we should not
be getting rid of insufferable people
the problem is what happens when people
become insufferable and they don't
constantly check in with the unforgiving
nature of the universe we have a problem
that sociologically nobody wants to say
that the institute for advanced study
has like the smartest guys around and a
lot of what they do is in physics in
standard terms it's the mathematics of
physics yeah and that these are
uncomfortable truths just the same way
that where it's uncomfortable that we're
taking seriously somebody who's been out
of the field for 27 years but these are
these are end times we're having end
time conversations and I think that it's
it's you know we don't need to be mean
about it I think it just needs to be
more honest that ship that you're seeing
is called curvature and it has three
masts because it has three irreducible
components usually one Mast is called
vile curvature one Mast is called
traceless Richie curvature and one mask
is called Richie scalar
and the first
greatest Insight maybe of the 20th
century was the way in which we could
feed back the curvature of the levitch
Vita connection into being a co-vector
field on the space of all metrics
and we this is depicted as a boat going
into a bottle that has a rather wide
opening so we've got a metric the metric
has a connection the connection produces
curvature that's Romanian we find that
by identities it's got three components
it tries to go towards metrics and the
Royal curvature is snapped off
afterwards the scalar curvature is
lowered somewhat or adjusted by scalar
curvature over two times G mu Nu
and so symbolically what we've done is
we've said Einstein threw away the vile
curvature readjusted the reachy scalar
curvature and fed metric information
through to the levy Javita connection
through to the Riemann curvature tensor
and then played these projection games
to feed it back to the space of metrics
in that particular combination is
perpendicular to the action of the
diffiomorphism group on the space of all
metrics uh leading to a Divergence free
condition via the our friend the Bianchi
identity so let's see whether general
relativity engaged Theory have an
incompatibility problem as we try to
play the same game we start off with the
Riemann curvature tensor but now the
neck is narrower
and what's really going on is is that
this is kind of evocative of trying to
feed it into the space of connections
but the gauge group
acts differently on two different
factors namely
if connections are add valued one forms
and curvature is a an ad or the algebra
value to form
the problem here is the gauge
Transformations act on the Lee algebra
component and don't touch the form
component
but einsteinian projection or
contraction or summing over G munu
indices
is democratic it deals simultaneously
with the form piece and the Lee algebra
piece so if you treat only the lead
algebra piece under a gauge
transformation you don't touch the form
piece then contraction followed by gauge
transformation will never be the same
thing as gauge transformation followed
by contraction so here's a GU approach
how do you get geometric Harmony between
general relativity engaged Theory when
you have the ship in a bottle problem
and this is kind of almost a tight
analogy you've got the curvature tensor
you apply a gauge transformation to two
of the masks
and you pass them through
into add value
D minus one forms and then you do an
inverse gauge transformation which is
exactly how you do the ship in the
bottle trick by the way Brian gave me a
wonderful ship in a bottle thank you
very much you're welcome raising the
masks inside and then you can
potentially if need be adjust one of the
two masks again in order to get
agreement
so in part the the idea is how do you
get Harmony
[Music]
let's imagine that we have a salary that
is constant in dollar terms over time
that somebody is facing uh inflationary
pressures on their basket of goods what
we now have is a ten dollar an hour
salary and if we claim that it's
constant constant means derivative
equals zero yes
but we know that it's not constant
purchasing power so we have two Notions
of constancy how are they related we do
a gauge transformation you now see that
these little hash lines
are the reference levels that we call a
connection and we decide that
rise over run should not be measured
from a naive horizontal but should be
measured instead from a custom reference
level represented by the hash mark
that situation is actually an
application of Game Theory to a very
simple problem in economics completely
depicted by stretching the fibers in the
X Y plane
toy model of space-time
so going around through the center is
like Groundhog Day you come back to the
same place and it's a repeating time
cycle
and space is simply a circle
and what you're seeing here is something
that's very hard to picture because it's
five-dimensional but one one trick here
is because the Taurus has a property
called parallelizability the object on
the right is a potential metric at any
given point on the Taurus
so in other words if a metric is a
symmetric non-degenerate two tensor
if you think of it as a matrix it would
be of the form
x z z y
and the non-degenerate means that x y
minus Z squared is not equal to zero so
that's what's cutting out that variety
if you will the zeros of the of the
determinants uh would be points given
that there are three degrees of freedom
in the metric
and so instead of actually having a
metric uh space time
gu would say replace the Taurus
by the entire space in that sort of
hourglassy region so the top region
would be like space space metrics the
bottom region below that sort of weird
uh diaphanous scarf is time time metrics
and the weird middle region
um which is sort of around that
Singularity would be space-time metrics
every way you can stick that donut into
that middle region without touching one
of those two sheets
is a valid space-time metric
and what gu would do is to say don't
only dance on the points of the
two-dimensional Taurus you should
actually have fields that are dancing on
all of the points of the Taurus and
simultaneously all of the points in that
middle region now notice that thing up
in the top left which is a ruler
protractor combination those two sliders
are recalibrations of what it means to
be one unit
and that protractor is a recalibration
of what you're going to Define to be 90
degrees
so every way of keeping that bottom arm
in a single horizontal position moving
the top arm and moving the two sliders
that's one of that's three degrees of
freedom in the space of metrics so
that's a different depiction of the
space of metrics so the the big take
home from the restrictive version of gu
that we're exploring here
is that if you allow fields to dance on
the space of metric apparatus
measurement apparatus that the kind of
the paradoxes of measurement start to
make a lot more sense
so the thing is is that Spinners on 14.
look like Spinners on four tensor
Spinners on some version of ten yeah and
whether you're talking about spin 10
models su5 models or su4 cross su-2
cross su2 which is Spin Six cross spin
four
isn't that exactly what we see in the
standard model
a particularly intriguing feature of
so10 which is really spin 10 or could be
spin 6 comma spin four is it spinner
representation used to house the quarks
and leptons in which the states have a
simple representation in terms of basis
States labeled by a set of plus and
minus signs perhaps this suggests
composite structure now here's the
sentence that just floored me
alternatively one could wonder whether
the occurrence of spinners both in
internal space and in space time is more
than a coincidence
and then he pulls back immediately these
are just intriguing facts they are not
presently Incorporated in any compelling
theoretical framework as far as I know
geometric Unity is that compelling
framework and one of the things I'm
looking to do is I'm looking to get
constructive feedback from people who
want to help me succeed as opposed to
people
who just want to be dicks and what I
would love is to bring your positive
energy reveal
go to geometric unity.org
physics is the most honest
way to ask the most grand questions in
the universe absolutely physics is great
then we've got real problems and Grand
doesn't exist and if Grand doesn't exist
then grandiose doesn't exist so my
feeling is no this is the actual Grand
Quest and we're not going to back off it
and be about it
[Music]
foreign